Let's be honest, your contribution to
the world so far is a browser history
you make sure no one sees. Incognito
tabs, deleted logs, hours gone, nothing
built. Now, contrast that with this. A
masjid is being completed in a village
in Norway where Muslims have nothing. It
will stand for generations. Those who
donate will be remembered by Allah. And
those who don't will quietly return to
the shadows, back to the consumption,
secrecy, and absolute nothing to show
for it. So, do the right thing. Post the
video or click the link below and donate
for your own akhirah.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh. How are you guys doing? I'm
joined with Orthodox Muslim. How you
doing? Good. Good. How are you? How are
you finding London? Beautiful, man.
Thank you for having me. Masha Allah.
You're a debater yourself. You've been
doing phenomenal work. Yeah. And another
person who's a great debater, to be
honest, is Mehdi Hasan, who's a very
educated Fantastic debater.
>> Fantastic debater. Seen a lot of his
clips, videos online. Yes. Well,
actually something has sparked a little
bit of controversy online recently of
his. Um I want you to watch it with me
and then come back and let's respond in
kind. I think that the problem with
education is that it focuses too much on
facts, too much on rigor, and not enough
on imagination.
>> Do you hear yourself? You talk about
this pretty far-right concept of Pax
Judaica, uh a new world order centered
around Israel. Surely you understand why
a lot of people think it best you're
trafficking in pretty anti-Semitic
tropes, and at worst, you're a
card-carrying anti-Semite.
>> So, so, what is wrong with the term Pax
Judaica? You tell me. So, as you can see
here, I mean, this is a trajectory of
Mehdi Hasan. And I I want to start off
by saying this, right? Mehdi Hasan has
been, as we say, an excellent advocate
for the Palestinian rights.
He's been a person who's very vocal
against Islamophobia,
against proponents against Islam, or
anti-Islamic proponents, or most
anti-Muslim proponents.
Uh however, he's also tried to straddle
this incongruent kind of middle ground
between Islam and left-wing politics,
okay? And the fact is uh orthodox
those two things are not compatible, are
they?
No, absolutely not. No. Yeah. So, I
mean, he's he's on the record um talking
about homosexual rights and how it's
bigotry and homophobia and these kind of
things, and he apologizes for his
previous views. But here, he starts
speaking about Pax Judaica, and he's
speaking to Professor Jang, okay, who he
um
questions the qualifications of
credentials of in the in the in the
But that's another issue for another
day. And he says to Professor Jang, he
says to him, "Well, that's an
anti-Semitic trope, actually, mentioning
Pax Judaica. We shouldn't be mentioning
that at all." Is is this a valid
criticism, do you think?
No, no, I I don't think so. Um it's it's
a very Jewish thing, actually. Mm.
>> Uh this has to do with the expansion of
Israel and Greater Israel.
>> Yeah, so I mean, Jews
>> he was saying, "Why don't you just call
it Greater Israel? Why'd you have to
mention Judaica in particular?" Is is
that is do you think this is
anti-Semitic?
No, no, it's it's not anti-Semitic. This
is what they believe. Mm. So, if you go
to uh Genesis chapter 15, for example,
um these are the borders that God
promises to Abraham and his descendants.
Um this is restated multiple times in
Exodus. It's restated um
again in Deuteronomy 17, I believe.
>> So, this is all the Old Testament, the
Torah, Old Testament, what Jews believe
is to be Yes. divine inspiration. Yes.
Yeah, so I mean, they're
they're very open about it. Uh this is
not hidden from anywhere. This is what
the Jews believe, that God promised
these lands to them. Uh these lands are
theirs by divine right.
Uh and so, no, I don't think there's
anything anti-Semitic about it. I think
it is the most, quote unquote, Semitic
thing, as a matter of fact.
>> And and this is a broader trend that
we're seeing from a lot of people on the
left. And obviously, Mehdi Hasan himself
is on the left, as we've just mentioned.
And he's straddling this impossible
middle ground
between being on the left on the one
hand and being a Muslim on the other.
Because as we've mentioned, and I'll
keep mentioning this point, but I think
it's an important one. There are things
which are completely incompatible.
Homosexuality is a sin in Islam.
Homosexuality is celebrated on the left.
For example, you know, feminism is
celebrated on the
>> let's just break down what he said
exactly about homosexuality again. Yeah,
so he um let me read exactly what he
said out. Um we can put it on the screen
as well. So, this is what he said. Um
He says the following. He says that I
now believe that you can't really live
in a secular society without supporting
a legal right to marry for same-sex
couples. I do, but still cringe um as I
remember how I made my own contribution
to homophobic discourse back in my 20s
over a decade ago.
I can only apologize. And another place
where he says something similar, he says
um as you can see here, I've always
regretted the dumb and offensive
comments I made in my 20s on atheism and
homosexuality.
So, as you can see, there's two things.
Uh and if he's talking about
homosexuality as a sin, then
I I don't know what he believes. I mean,
this is something that probably should
be asked him.
Uh especially from people on the on the
left. Does he believe that um
homosexuality is a sin, and therefore
the people that are committing it are
sinful? Or does he believe that it's
bigoted, in his language, to um refer to
these people in that way? And you know
what? It's a fair question because he
does represent Muslims politically.
>> Yes. He does. Yes. Right? Uh and so I
think it's very fair for him to clarify
his position on such a crucial matter.
Yeah. Uh because we all know Islam's
very clear on this issue. Uh that
homosexuality is sinful. Um you just
have to call a spade a spade. So, I'm
very interested in in in seeing how he's
going to
>> How he replies to that because it's it's
these things that Okay, we want Muslim
representation, but we don't want to
compromise. And we're seeing the you
know,
I think he actually also supports
transgender rights.
What What's the Islamic stance on that?
What's the Islamic stance on feminism?
What's the Islamic stance on all these
things on the left that are celebrated?
So, he's straddling an impossible middle
ground. And it's about time he makes a
decision and he's clear about what he
believes in. But, I'm surprised he
hasn't been pressed on it.
Yeah, me too. I mean, I I I see him all
over the place. And just to mention
again, he is a very eloquent speaker,
very charismatic, very smart. He knows
how to argue. He delivers excellent
points.
But, these issues must be clarified. And
as somebody who again represents Muslims
politically on a world stage.
I mean, he's his interviews and his
video clips do tens of millions of
views.
And you know, we all kinds of
demographics see these. So, I think it's
important to to clarify because like you
said,
these are things that we as Muslims,
especially in the West, we cannot
compromise
on. These are These are our values. I
want to circle back to the point that
you are making about Pax Judaica and
stuff like that and ask you another
question because
now one of the government definitions in
fact of uh anti-Semitism in this country
is that if you criticize people on the
on on the basis of their religion as a
Jew, right?
But, do we have to subscribe to that or
is it within our right as the Quran does
to theologically, all right,
contradict and contravene or repudiate
or refute aspects of Jewish theology?
Number one. And number two,
are there
things that you've read cuz you you're a
comparative religionist, you've read
this stuff and you just speak about this
stuff every day.
In the Talmud, which is I know you're
doing a course on, is that stuff that
you
>> I'm not doing a course on the Talmud.
Oh, you know. I'm doing a course on
Christianity. Oh, okay. Yeah, but I've
we've we've Yeah, I've looked at it.
Yeah. So, tell me now. I mean, in terms
of that in terms of the Talmud, uh is it
very clear from your reading that in
fact there is this mainstream
interpretation of otherizing every
gentile person?
I'm doing what to every gentile?
>> Like otherizing them or Otherizing them?
Oh, okay.
Uh yes. So, there's a clear distinction.
This is agreed upon by all Jews. Nobody
disagrees that um our identity is we are
um Bene Israel. So, we are the children
of Israel and the others are gentiles.
Um so, there are different categories,
different labels. They have a label for
heretics.
They call them minim, heretics. They
have a label for apostates. They have a
label for what they call aliens.
So, these are um gentiles who live in uh
Eretz Israel, the land of Israel.
Okay, and they have classifications for
all of these people. But, yes, um this
is very clear throughout the Torah and
the Talmud uh that we are the children
of Israel and they are gentiles. Um as a
matter of fact, there are uh discussions
in the in Avodah Zarah in the Talmud uh
in different rabbinical texts where
gentiles are um said to be uh in some
discussions uh unworthy of life if they
are not righteous gentiles because they
do distinguish between a righteous
gentile.
That is a gentile who is a what the uh
rabbinic Jews called Noahide.
So, this term Noahide is not in the
Torah, but they do extract it from the
Torah. So, these are the laws of Noah
that Noah and his people followed. So,
stay away there seven, stay away from
sexual morality, stay away from
idolatry, from strangled meat, from food
sacrificed out the things of that sort.
All right? Um, and yeah, so you do have
rulings in the Talmud uh,
where some rabbis would say that if a
and I'll put it up on the screen, uh, if
a Jew
murders a Gentile, hm, then he's exempt
from punishment. Hm, really? Yeah, yeah,
all kinds of rulings. The point is that
>> case, I mean, Jang, cuz his retort to
uh, Mehdi Hasan was that what's wrong
with this term Pax Judaica? Right. Uh,
cuz what what Jang has been doing is
also been invoking like secret societies
and so I'm not sure if you've heard his
uh, content on that. But he's basically
saying that I mean, some people say it's
conspiratorial, but that's a different
discussion.
Essentially, he's saying that there is
some Jewish-inspired,
okay,
um, beliefs uh, that actually come from
these texts that you're talking about.
And that influenced the world in the way
that we we know it now, we see it now.
Is that plausible as a political
explanation for you or is that
anti-Semitic, would you say?
No, I I don't think there's an- anything
anti-Semitic about it because it's it's
very clear and it it actually baffles me
sometimes because rabbis
are very dogmatic on this as a matter of
fact. So, there is this one rabbi and
I'm sure many people have heard of him,
seen clips of him. Uh, his name is
Youssef Mizrahi. Hm. Okay? So, he's uh,
he's a there's a very popular clip of
him
uh, that everybody knows where he
basically says
that he says, "Idol worshiper," I'm
quoting him word for word, "Idol
worshiper Hm.
they don't have the right to live." And
so, he starts calculating how many
people are in the world. So, he goes
through India and China and all of these
um, idolatrous nations, so
non-monotheistic nations. And he
basically says that and he includes
Christians as well. And he says,
"Idol-worshipping Christians."
Uh so, he doesn't include Muslims cuz he
views us as monotheistic, obviously. So,
he says that about 80% of the world does
not have the right to live because, and
I quote, "They make Hashem angry every
single day by their idolatry." And um
and other uh comments as well. And these
are not things that are
um uh uh kind of extreme. Mhm. Uh he's
not uh an extremist Jew. Rather, this is
exactly what Talmudic Judaism teaches.
And
uh
it's it's it's translated as You can go
on sefaria.org.
Everybody can go ahead and read it.
Actually, some rabbis would say that a
gentile
uh is who reads the Torah should be
executed. So, this actually a ruling
that exists. So, and again, remember,
not all of these rulings are
um universally agreed upon because uh
so, the Talmud has uh discussions
between rabbis that go back and forth
between uh legal rulings and discussions
and stuff like that. Uh there there
You know, rulings do exist where if you
are a gentile, mhm, you are not allowed
to read the Talmud or the Torah because
uh this is something too holy for you to
understand.
And this is not sent for you.
It's rather sent for the children of
Israel. Right? Uh so, yeah,
back to my point. It baffles me that
this is They're very vocal about this.
If you know, if you go to Israel, all
these rabbis that do discussions and
speeches, they're very vocal about this.
And so, if they can say it and they can
be vocal about it, then there's nothing
wrong with us pointing it out. There's
nothing anti-Semitic about it at all. I
mean, cuz we do talk about the fact
that, you know, you've got Zionism. And
sometimes we say we we give a Zionist
critique. We say this is Zionism and and
it's not all Jewish
people. It's not Judaism. It's Zion- We
make this distinction with Zion- So so
that we can avoid the anti-Semitic
label. But the fact is this, Zionism is
not a one-way street. In fact, some of
Zionism is inspired by the extreme and
radical and supremacist interpretations
of Judaism. That's right. And and I
mean, Ezisha made a very good point
actually which I retweeted and it went
viral which is that we speak about
radical Islam quite openly. I mean, the
Western academics speak about radical
Islam. But no one no one speaks about
radical Judaism. Nobody. And and I in
fact, if you look at the Talmud and
these you know, scriptures that you're
talking about,
it's all there. And so, look, I I think
that Mehdi Hasan is doing this because
there's an aspect of him with respect
and I don't want to disrespect anybody
here cuz he's as I say a great advocate
for Palestine.
He's a careerist. He's doing this
because he's a journalist, right? And
he's trying to further his career and
that's what journalists do.
But one could, if I was to be very
harsh, say, "Well, don't, you know, wait
for a pat on the head, okay, from the
left-wing colonizer to try and prop up
left-wing left, you know, liberal
talking points at the expense of the
Islamic discourse." I mean, he's on the
record already speaking about blasphemy
laws or apostasy laws and attacking
these things in countries that do it. He
attacks theocracies and he doesn't like
it. We don't even know where he stands.
So my message to Mehdi Hasan would be
the following is that we have to really
come to get to the bottom of
what do you believe in?
Do you believe in secularism or do you
believe in
Islam Islam governed systems? It doesn't
have to be a particular, you know,
representation that like for example,
Iran or these interpretations. We're
talking about the actual premise.
And if you don't believe in Islam being
implemented, then what do you do with
the verses in the Quran which clearly
indicate that doing the opposite of that
is
for example,
Um, know, do you prefer the hukum or the
judgment of a jahiliyyah?
What do you do of the verses in the
Quran that talk about homosexuality? Are
they wrong Is the Quran wrong? Is the
Quran a bigoted book? What do you do of
the um
verse in the Quran which criticizes the
Jewish clergy? Methalul latheena humilo
taurat thumma lam yahmiluha kamathalil
himari yahmilu asfara. That the
similitude of the one who holds the
taurat
and doesn't uh uphold it is like the
donkey carrying back uh books on his
back. And many other criticisms of
Judaism as a religion. Are these
anti-Semitic aspects of the Quran? Are
you willing to concede that? These are
questions that I have uh I'm really
surprised because he interrogates her.
Nobody uh cuz he considers himself a
Muslim or he considers himself a Shiite
Muslim and this is not a Shiite Sunni
issue anyway. Nobody has had the thought
in their mind, okay, he says he's a
Muslim and he says he's a left-wing
liberal. These things are
incommensurate, they're incongruent or
they're otherwise incompatible. Let's
ask him if the Quran is wrong here or if
the Quran is right. And if the Quran is
right and meant for all times and
places,
then how do you excuse X, Y, and Z?
>> Well, remember when you were reading his
tweet earlier, he's saying that he
uh he's he feels apologetic towards his
dumb comments and dumb views. So, I'm
wondering, does he think that what the
Quran says is dumb? Does he Does he
think that uh the Quranic uh position on
these issues is cringey like he said?
Mhm. So, I mean, it's interesting to
think about.
>> and to be honest, these are questions
that we we said the same thing with
Hamza Yusuf, the not the the Sufist but
the uh politician. Yeah.
>> Right.
Um
we said the same thing about uh what do
you call it? Mamdani who he supports by
the way unconditionally by the looks of
it as well. And he was kind of like a
mascot for him in his Yeah. uh campaign.
And we we have the right to ask him the
same questions. He's a public figure
like you said representing Muslims.
These questions need to be asked. Now,
based on your answers to these
questions, left-wing people will know
what you are, Muslim people will know
what you are, and then we can all deal
with you accordingly. But, at the
moment, you're trying to straddle an
impossible middle ground, and I hope
that you come to your senses and come
back to the Quran and Sunnah, come back
to the book of Allah, and represent
Muslims cuz you will be, as you already
are, a shining star in our community for
conservative Islam, actually the true
Islam.
And with that, is there anything you
want to say at the end of it? No, no,
that's it. Looking forward to hear back,
I guess. Yes. Well, with that, we
conclude with salaam alaikum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh. You probably
don't deserve to watch this video. Your
level is honestly too low to watch this
video. So, feel free to click away from
the video. But, for the few who can
handle responsibility, we're building
the only masjid in a village in Norway.
First payment is already done. Final
500,000 remaining. Huge sadaqah jariya
waiting. If you're serious about Islam,
you'll pause the video and you'll click
the link below to donate right now. If
not, enjoy the comment section.